You're an app for harassing Zaza for a whole hour and making
her upset even after we said to stop said to stop. [music] Now
I'm getting the harassment tenfold. Sorry to hear that.
>> He really He really just hit her with I'm sorry to hear
that. Dude, she did that whole thing. Nine Nine messages, I'm
sorry to hear that. I'm sorry to hear that.
In a nutshell, there was a Marvel Rivals tournament with a $40,000
prize purse. There was a player by the name of Kingsman who really
wanted to take this
I I'm literally only here for his voice over so that I can start
going to the thread and covering it myself. I'm just getting
the quick sum up of what he's going to say right now. >> making
a mention that this money would be very helpful to him as a college
student. And the rest of the team didn't seem to take it all
that seriously and eventually
when Kingsman was trying to you know make changes to the team
comp so they could better stand a chance at winning, they all
attacked him and eventually it led to him getting kicked from
the tournament. His team then went on to place second to last
in the
Okay, guys.
Case and point proven right now. Do you
How do you not think it's a problem right now?
He got kicked in scrims.
No, no, no, no, no. She shouldn't be dead. I'm getting value
because I'm one v sixing. >> isn't peeling for you, bro.
Yeah, Zaza is Owen five, but we won the point, bro.
Wait, is this one of those mix is So this is like it's Marvel
Rivals, but is it Twitch Rivals where they do like a split team
with like different influencers and stuff?
Very based. Cool. We're going to go through all this stuff. We
will get to some more of the Tazzo stuff later, okay? Tazzo did
do nothing wrong.
I I just feel like this is going to be right for my general takes,
my general misogyny. I also feel bad that Sophia donated for
my misogyny, but Why? Because they're hard like four people are
dying or dying four four of their you tell four of their resources
are all spent on Zaza. So you I saw this a couple days ago and
I was so confused why anyone would be joining a tournament if
they didn't ac- actually care about winning at all. So he is
very clearly trying his best to help the
Okay. All right. He's giving directions. They're not listening.
He's He's trying really hard.
The women are just like I I get it a little bit, okay?
Here Let's read the the sum up in the We'll start with this and
we're going to just go through this thread. I've been told that
this thread is a very good summation of the drama overall, okay?
So I'm going to roll with this thread.
We'll see how it goes, okay?
It's It's you know, chronological. It should be There has been
a lot of drama memes that has come out of the Creator Cup and
wanted to create a mega thread to cut down all the incoming posts.
No other posts will be allowed regarding the drama outside. Discuss
any updates in here as well. Mega thread will be updated maybe
with upcoming news. Please keep in mind not to attack anybody
individually. Meme and keep it civil. This thread will be used
to lay out the timeline. I did not watch all the statements or
videos, just gathering the information and everything has come
out or everything that has came out and laying it out. Deadpool
Creator Cup was originally intended to be just a content creator
style draft tournament with no prize pool when people were invited
originally and then prize pool was later added on. Hosted by
Basim Z ZB. Basim ZB.
Flows better that way. The tournament features streamers slash
content creators from every region with every skill level. The
tournament had a draft system where captains picked their team.
Teams were picked and team Sorry, teams were picked and teams
were practicing prior to the tournament. Kingsman265
got kicked from the tournament and he made a video as to why
he was kicked. His team had Zaza stack, the Black Widow player,
as well as Cece as the team captain. After Kingsman got kicked,
the team placed seventh out of eight teams.
I was kicked.
Was Kingsman their really good player? Oh, let's go. Let's
go. I'm ready. Oh, I'm ready. I'm ready. I'm ready. The I'm letting
the misogyny flow through me, okay? I'm definitely going to take
the guy's side if he was good. Okay, it's just going to happen.
We're watching. We're locked in. out from a $40,000
streamer tournament. If you guys do not know, Basim ZB is hosting
a tournament called the Deadpool Creator Cup and it's where 48
creators are all coming together in order to show Deadpool and
play the new season for a cash prize of $40,000 sponsored by
NetEase and I was removed from it. Now, I know this is not my
typical style of videos, but
Pull it. What do you want me to pull, Canadian caller? >> I
just need to
Like who we're going to agree with? Okay, yeah. Come on, man.
Come on Come on, man.
Come on, man. Come on, man. Come Come on, man. insane. What actually
happened is I'm prefacing this video. Do not harass anybody you
see in this video. If you go to their stream and you harass them
or hate or say anything to any of them, I will ban you from my
stream. Do not do that. I've been saying this throughout the
entirety since the start of the tournament and I will continue
to say so. I'm starting this video with what happened yesterday
so you guys can see it from the average perspective of a viewer
coming into my stream at that time. From someone who hasn't seen
any of the previous days. I'm also going to show the drafting
day and if you want to see the first scrimmage day as well, go
take a look at all the VODs. They are currently up on my Twitch
channel. If you want to see the full thing for yourself at Kingsman265_Twitch.
Without further ado, here is the video.
Okay, so I'm going to need It doesn't sound like he's taking
like the the scrimmage stuff and putting it out there like honestly,
right? Seems like he's kind of not including some of the scrimmage
stuff right away, which it sounds like that's where he was getting
really upset with them or where they were getting picked at him,
right? He just said like I didn't do that. I only covered the
first day of the tournament or something. Give me like full try
hard for these scrims. Like take a try hard treat it like it's
like the real tournament. Oh, never mind. No, I mean like hard
calm and [__] Like I want to focus like I need to
win this Can we do that? Please? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I got you.
All right.
Who's our sub by the way cuz Big Buffer's not going to be here,
right?
Is anybody else coming? Do they remember?
I know Buffer's not coming. I'll go on Lucy's channel and be
like
Yeah, scrims.
Oh my god, yeah, I do have scrims. I do have Okay, she just totally
forgot that we had scrims. Hey, we're all here.
>> He's already angry. He's already No, is Spencer's team
here? Let's go.
Hey, we've got scrims. Did you forget? Did you forget? Yeah,
she did forget. Why Kabaru, why are you watching my stream? Literally
watching my stream commenting in the chat, bro. I can ask in
the server. Maybe somebody's like can talk about um somebody
else wants to scrim or something. I don't Can we just run quickly
so that we can like go again? Um yeah, we can I guess, man. I
mean, I can maybe better, but like we don't have I don't think
everyone can play I can go I can go into a GM account. I have
a GM
I can log into the Nuzlocke account, Wait, wait, wait. If we're
a six stack with mics, we should totally be playing. Everybody
Is everybody in here GM? Uh I'm diamond one. I was predicted
GM three and then I played with a Deadpool player. Can a diamond
[laughter] Can diamond one queue
uh with GMs?
All right, let me log into my other account and
um we can we can do that as practice. I feel bad though for >> Dude,
I kind of
I do kind of wonder if I could like go into these games and still
be good at them. I I kind of wonder sometimes. Like how good
could I be in Marvel Rivals if I just went Could I go make like
GM pretty easily? I think I almost certainly could.
I'm pretty sure I I basically automatically could. You're washed?
Yeah, but the thing about over I was washed when I made GM in
Overwatch. I was washed when I made top like 500 or whatever,
200. I forget. I was washed when I did that in Overwatch. These
games The whole point of these games is that you could be totally
washed. You can have no aim and still win.
That's the whole point of these games, right? That you could
be totally washed. You could suck and it doesn't matter cuz you
could just play some tank role and be smarter than other people
and just know the mechanics and win easily. Is that not true?
I feel like that's true. That's got to It was true for Overwatch.
Got to be true. I thought Marvel Rivals was more casual than
Overwatch. Uh Fumi cuz Fumi is a sub,
If it's literally about having situational awareness when a bunch
of stuff is flying around, I could be GM super easily.
Like obviously >> We need to Unless this is main new Let's
rank up, but I don't want to waste time, you know, cuz she's
Sorry about Yeah, we just need practice cuz What else is my Nuzlocke
password? >> I low-key think Buffer is also busy tomorrow.
So like Bro.
I forgot to sign. Yeah, a little bit >> Oh,
what's my PC
Oh, [laughter] and I just leaked the alt account email. Good
thing it's the alt account. You invite Hit Space can We still
have an upper hand by having a Gambit in his back line. Well,
that's the thing. It's Orpo is really good with triple. That's
what makes him really good. It's triple
And then he I don't want to run triple
We're not going to
Check that ping. Wait, what do you mean check that ping? Like
tank full.
Oh. Oh, that's brutal. 174 of us. Where is this person?
Where is this person that they're They got to be a support player,
right? I don't think they are though. They They were like getting
the most before. That is distressing, isn't it?
Cuz they were In the previous one, they got the most
In the pre- in their like first random game they signed up for,
she had she had most with him. So that makes me think
by having a Gambit in his back line. Well, that's the thing.
It's Orpo is really good with triple. That's what makes him really
good. It's triple support. [laughter] And then he I don't want
to run triple Bro. We're not going to run triple support in the
tournament. No, I don't Where did you get that idea that we were?
She we lost.
>> Where is the triple support coming from? Okay, then
we don't play okay, well,
this is going to be a hard a hard 20
I would I would actually play this game with people, but I'm
going to have to wait cuz I think all the people I know who play
this game are probably playing high tail right now instead. So,
I don't know anyone else who plays. If I wanted to try it, I
think we would have to wait a little bit.
No, I play another stream.
It's [laughter] a it's a $40,000 20
We're going to need triple support.
I think [laughter] you guys have a very different mentality than
like other teams like I think other teams would just walk out
with full. Thank you. Of course they're going to do that. It's
a $40,000 tournament. No, they're not. Talk some sense into these
guys cuz they don't want to run triple support. He asked if they
could play seriously and now they said yeah, we can play seriously
and now they're like I just want to play what I usually play.
But every team will.
This is
I'm
seeing I'm seeing every single problem I expected.
Dude, all I swear to God this happens with women all of the time
in these games is they're like well, I only know how to play
this and it's like yeah, but unfortunately like if you play that
at like the 99th percentile if you play play this better than
anybody else,
it's still going to be worse than you just basically only knowing
how to hit like left trigger or whatever the buttons you need
to hit. If you can use this one ability, it's energized with
a comp that's going to be way better. So, just do it. Just do
it, okay?
He's not willing to change either. Okay, but I assume and correct
me if I'm wrong is he by far the best is he like their pro player
who can actually do his
Who will like actually be a game changer if he does his DPS?
And he wants to win? Yeah, so like that's why he doesn't want
to change.
Obviously. You don't think any team will want to run triple support?
If Natsu's playing for 40 grand, he's going to play triple support.
Guys, just cuz you can I can learn him too and play him. Uh you
need two tank stuff for triple support. People are telling me
that
I The funny thing is the reason I don't play these games by the
way is because I am too old. I don't care enough to put the time
in and like
maybe people just don't get this. Most people who are at like
the top of the ladder, they don't play these games for This is
like I'm literally doing this as like a challenge to my brain.
Like this is like it's not for fun. It is we are being serious,
okay? We're being serious right now. This is not this is not
around time. Dude, I care if I played these games, I would care
way less. Sorry, I would care way more about playing the game
than like you know, analyzing drama before I go live. Like there's
just no reason to play these games unless you are playing them
seriously. So, I don't have enough time. So, I don't play them
at all. Yeah, I can play second tank. I play
in games, okay?
He died while he was eating? Oh, did he?
If we play Simi's team
Saza, do you want to play Bucky? Can you play Bucky? Are you
going to mean Bucky or what do you got?
>> Widow is not multi anti dive though.
Like I'm telling you.
I can already see this going off the rails, okay? She's playing
like a sniper with a 180 ping and their entire comp is going
to rely on her hitting shots. Like if there's dive comps, right?
It's going to be going for your back line supports. She's going
to hit those shots. First shot, right? You have to hit that shot.
You're you're running your entire comp around somebody who's
a sniper with a 180 ping. She needs to hit that first shot. It
it's just never going to happen. I can see exactly how this is
going to be totally broken. It's like it's over.
It's important to draft a good composition before the round starts
or before the match starts.
Widow in rivals is even worse, well
Yeah, I
don't know how to tell you when you keep asking like
>> For Christmas, I want Saza to play Bucky Phoenix Allah
and we win the tournament for $40,000.
Guys, if we're banking on the fact that they're not going to
take it seriously, then we're going to lose.
Now, I will say okay, if you want me to go against this guy,
he's not acting this is not optimal,
You you literally cannot
[__] around and do [__] like this when
you're playing with like women streamer gamers, okay? These women
are all going to have the same attitude. You have to understand
how to communicate, okay? You do have to understand that this
will never work. You are like the exact thing that they would
be totally against, right? They're they're like going to mock
you. You're like the caricature of the thing they mock when they
stream. Right? So, you do have to understand that they basically
with their audiences probably can't
sort of give into this.
You you have to be like asking. You can't be demanding. You just
you and you have you can't be whiny. You can't be like forcing
it too hard.
you might even have to give, you know, a game here or there.
Like just go, hey,
why don't you like test it out first and we'll see and if we
go through the first game and it looks like it's like not working,
could we maybe reevaluate, right? Like something like that. CC
wouldn't have drafted a black widow um one trick pony. Yeah,
sure. Sure, that's true.
If it's a if she's a one trick pony black widow, that's We should
be banking it on [laughter] the fact that they are going to take
it as seriously as
Worst case scenario will happen.
Which means probably not, right? Yes, that we're going to lose
if [laughter] they run triple support. If they have something
that they can
No, no, no. If they have something that they can run and they
automatically win, they are going to play it if it's
Like at this point the other thing that's going on here
they've made their points, okay? They've made their points and
you can
you can already sense you're losing. You can't now ruin the mental
of your team if you want to win, okay? Now you're now you're
dragging down the mental of the whole team. It sounds like he's
getting out voted.
Which sucks, but it sounds like he's getting out voted, okay?
You got to disagree and commit and move forward, okay? You got
to do it. You got to do it, man. A lot of money. It's a lot of
money.
Go go go go go go go go go.
Is is the game like lagged or something?
What is wrong with this person?
Who is this character right here and why are they like basically
not looking over at him and trying to do anything? They're like
not even looking at him. Maybe maybe they just have no escape
at all, nothing to do.
But like he's on top of them. He's basically like not even aware
of where he is, it looks like. It looks like she's basically
just like oh, I'm dead. Do you do you see my point? Now, imagine
Saza trying to live that, right? It's not going to happen.
Yeah, exactly exactly. I'm like learning him. But Bucky will.
If Bucky will prevent that.
>> They're living with triple support.
Okay, so
Um you have the best chance of winning by putting me on Widow.
I mean like
If she's going to switch to Widow
Oh, this is going to be hard, but you can like get a Mantis.
If you think you like a Mantis that's
I I think everybody's doubting her, but she's literally she just
saved me and Casey's life.
If you have like a Widow as a solo DPS like you're going to need
then we have no front line with
No, no, no, like I I can run well, I don't know about your other
player that's not here, but like I can run that pool for a bit.
Uh what does that Gambit do that he's got on him? What is that
debuff? What is that doing to him?
I I played him for like 10 hours in early access.
Is that a bot or a debuff? [laughter]
No, there was
The pie and do more damage and more >> Listen guys, it's
important to have this down pat before the tournament. We need
to know our solid composition. What do we do? Our solid composition
is her on freaking Black Widow. Then if that is your win con,
we will automatically lose. You cannot have that as a Yeah, this
this is he's he doesn't understand that he can't do this. It's
too bad.
Um these guys aren't that far apart in terms of their ranks.
The the Black Widow's in a lower rank. But like they're not that
far apart in terms of their ranks. He can't be that much better
than them, right?
He got drafted onto this team, yes.
Seems like a good player. You have the worst mindset, bro. I'm
telling the truth.
No, you're not because you don't know. I do know.
Bro, if the game comes down to one person being win condition,
we're going to lose no matter is not one
No, I So it sounds like
Could I Could I actually do this graphically still? I don't know
if I can do this graphically. Essentially, you've got like this
team, okay? You've got this You've got a front line, you got
some tanks. They hold they they basically create a way for you
to move forward into some area to capture an objective. You've
got DPS and supports. Your DPS are going to try to their supports
usually cutting around their tanks or sometimes you can hold
them back and get them to the other DPSs they dive you, right?
Depending on what's going on. But you you will usually have a
support or a tank that can do something called peeling. When
somebody's getting focused, you need to wait you need to wait
to help, okay? In every one of these games in every MOBA that
exists, whether it's a first-person shooter MOBA or a top-down
MOBA, what you need is a way to defend somebody who's getting
targeted. The other team will essentially put a skull over somebody's
head. They're going to say, "We're going to go for this character."
You need to wait to help that person and make sure they don't
die. Now, what they're trying to do for their peel is have a
sniper who will be able to kill somebody who is diving like
that is incredibly low probability, incredibly low chance to
have happen,
And you can do that. You can That might even be the most effective
way to do things, right? It's possible that you could run that
in competitive and it works. Usually, when you have a really
high chance of failure, at the highest levels that's where things
are bad, right? So you you try to go to for things that are more
reliable. It sounds like there's some characters they want, whoever
Bucky is. I guess that's what is
it's Bucky
It's Captain America's buddy with the arm, right? I don't know
what he does in this game. But that's what they want him They
want her to play him so that he can like live and also peel off
of someone else, right? Winter Soldier, right? So I don't know
what his abilities are, but it's like they want that guy so that
he can like live and and peel off of people. Maybe he's got something
to help peel or maybe he's just tankier, I don't
that's what they want.
I don't know it It does feel like I'm on his side that if you
just have a Black Widow and that's your your secondary DPS instead
of a instead of a third support, you take a Black Widow as your
secondary DPS or third DPS maybe,
I that feels Person being the win condition, it is a fact that
we have to revolve the comp around one person. If that is the
case, play your character. What do you mean? You're still able
to play magic. She's just going to bleed be on Black Widow. That
doesn't change anything. Like The difference between Bucky Hook
is that Okay, so what's the difference between a 5v6 and a 6v6?
Are you going to tell me I will play support to make you happy
if
He's He's basically being as much of an as possible and guaranteeing
that they can never give in to him. It's It's too bad that There's
ways to do this. He's just He's made it so that they can't give
in to him now. He's just being way too much of
Like it's going to be like we're 5v6. She's going to not do anything.
She's just going to stop. Three people diving Zarya. That means
there's three people in our backline on Zarya. They are going
to explode Zarya in 0.2 seconds and then go on our supports.
They are.
That is how it works. Why are you doubting her this much though?
Like at this point, you say let's go to a scrim, right? Let's
go to a scrim and if they get a scrim against a team that's roughly
the same skill,
they should be able to especially if they get scrims directly
against other teams who are playing or something, they should
be able to help. Or sorry, they should be able to tell what's
going to happen. They'll get a little preview.
I'm not doubting her. You are misunderstanding. You're misunderstanding.
I have played Widow. I played Widow. I have like I have like
20 hours on her. If we were to remove If we were to remove Black
Widow from the comp and go Bucky or whatever, they're still going
to dive as hard and they're Yes, but if we have Bucky, they are
going to get on so hard. Why they're playing Bucky so
Bucky is so simple though. That's the thing. It takes 5 seconds
to learn.
Widow is like what she's best at. You're saddling her on a character.
Exactly, exactly. But even if she's not that good on the character,
the character gets 200% more value than Widow. Regardless, you
could be dodge on Bucky and get No, it is true. It is true. You
don't know how it works. I'm on that right now. You think I'm
getting 200%
No, I can play support well. Do you know how hard it's going
to be if we fight Snake Case and he has 2,000 HP? What if we
run triple support and you could be the third Then we have no
main. I am the only other DPS.
arguing about, bro. He wants Zarya just off of Bucky. I just
want main damage. I want frontline damage. If we don't have frontline
pressure, we will lose. I already said I will play triple support
if [laughter] we need it. That's not frontline pressure. That's
not what I'm saying. Triple is another issue. Before you attack,
get The triple is good, but like the He's He's too much. He's
too much.
Apart Dude, he's just got a
He's just got to realize he's being way too much right now that
nobody would ever give in to this right now. He's He's like way
over the top. He could have just been like, "Let's play scrims.
See how it goes." I I think this is going to be a problem. And
if it is a problem, can we, you know, talk about this again?
And yeah, it is it's probably too late. It's impossible. It's
over. It's over.
Why not?
Because I'm not swapping off of Black Widow. Okay, then we lost
the tournament. GG. Go next. That's literally [laughter] how
it works.
He's being a [__] man.
Not good, dude.
No, bro. I'm just going to make another video, bro, for sure.
No, this is an important conversation.
This is an important conversation to have before a $40,000 tournament.
You're going to have to revolve a 2-3-2 comp around like her
being the win condition. And that's going to be really hard.
Really, really hard. Especially if
Blank, infantilization is not acting like a human being, just
so you're aware, okay? I see you saying, "End all infantilization."
That's not what it is. By the way, when guys do this to each
other, you know what a guy would do here? They would tell you
to eat They go play Bucky or something and they'd never cast
their spells correctly. They'd just see, okay? Like You understand,
you're just you're failing with a man or a woman here. The woman
is just trying to keep things together. A guy would tell you
to off and leave or a guy would tell you to off and try to get
you kicked. Like there's a million other ways a guy would handle
this, okay?
Nobody Nobody handles this guy being like this that way. Snake
Case and Gregor on the enemy team. If they Yeah, if they go badly,
All right, let's lock in right now. Snake Case is on the enemy
team in clips. Let's let's lock in.
I've got one One of us One of us
One of us
One of you One of you One of you
One of you
I just saw her die to Spider-Man there in the exact way he was
talking about.
You hear me? This
I give a [__]
>> [__] I didn't mean to do that. That was
honestly on me. I doubt the man.
What guys I've got I've got I've got one One of you
One of you One of you One of you
he's carrying so hard. Oh boy.
Yeah. Wait, wait, wait, wait. You Do you know how to do the the
V hop? What he saw condition, no.
It's in the There's a certain angle you got to leave on for a
V hop.
I was looking at my book or whatever the
I've got both supports.
I've got one of us. There's three of us.
You are mocking me before it's too late. With the amazing Spider-Man.
What I'm going to die.
I think
I think I think
We have uh we've got him for next fight.
You can get him. Yeah, nice, nice, nice. One of us One of us
He's [laughter] going to play the whole scrim.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go. You make sure you fill this spot.
I hope I'm not wrong.
>> I think he's trying to play with the whole scrim so
you can see like how good he is.
That's like I do get it. It shouldn't be
How do you not see a problem right now,
bro? Oh, no. How do you not see a problem right now? I do understand.
I understand both sides of this situation. How do you not see
a problem right now? It's 18 to one. She's 0-5. That ass kingsman,
like shut the [__] up. Okay, bro. Lucy's not even
on inviz. You're getting value because No, no, no, no, she shouldn't
be dead. I'm getting value because I 1v6 isn't peeling for you,
bro. You have 1-5, but we won the point, bro. Why? Because they're
hard like Four people are dying here. That four of their youtels,
four of their resources are all spent on Zarya. Show you that
against the enemy team.
Dude, uh
I Unfortunately, that's like part of his point, too. Is he saying
obviously we have a Widow who's fragile, they're going to dive
you, right? And then you're on 200 ping trying to figure it
Guys, listen. You may not want the money, but I do, okay? I really
want to win. I need money for college, I need money for everything.
And I want to try my hardest to get the right composition. It
doesn't matter what >> I will do, it's not happening. This
game, maybe we consider it again, but like I don't think bro.
Calm down, little bro.
All right, he's still tanking. He's still tanking, too.
I'm skipping parts.
>> Oh, he's got wrecked. He just got wrecked. It's over.
>> Well, they used Sue, they
I need to see the scoreboard there.
Can I see the scoreboard, please?
Two and eight. She's two and eight now.
Don't worry, Kings.
Three kills, Zaza. I'll send you 50K
Uh she's six and eight. She kind of picked it up a little bit.
Well, they're pretty good at Angela. Maybe we should
Okay, hold on. I probably I probably need whatever these comps
are here. Like a Widow, honestly, she is a hit or miss, but I
think Zaza like what like literally just watch her play. I think
she can take care of herself. Even if her stats don't show it,
I think she was doing great for herself.
Like that could be true, by the way. She could be doing fine.
She could be doing like kind of good for herself. But why would
you ever think that that's like a thing? Why would you ever assume
that when you can't see her point of view? You literally can't
see it.
Widow is a She's She's a hit or miss character. Like some games
>> Listen, guys. I have no
>> Honestly, yeah, but >> I'm just I'm just saying
purely and solely for the composition, like Bucky or something
that can peel for the sports if you're getting perma-dove like
that is better. Because Widow is so frail and so squishy, and
I know this cuz I've gone against every Black Widow, number one
Black Widow, all of them, and you run full dive in a top Elo,
you just dive her and you explode her like a bug. That's just
what happens.
That's such a That's such a good point. You're so right about
that, and we're still going to play Widow. I I don't know what
to do. I'll vote everyone Yeah, you got to you got to accept
that they're going to force Widow. [laughter]
I mean, there's there's a work around. Like you just got to make
a good comp around her. Okay, so should I play Mantis there or
you play Loki? Loki Mantis Gambit?
I think I think you just accept that like uh We we will have
a dive tank to dive with you. You know what I mean?
What is the other tank play? Like what dive tank does he play?
You can run like an Angela, Magic, Kings. You would have to run
Sue.
Jay stock is like a guy seeing whole game cuz you picked Techies.
I play Techies. What are you talking about?
I I don't get tilted. I played What The last time I played, I
played Morana, Clockwork, Techies.
Uh Rubik, maybe. I play characters that it doesn't matter what
you play. I can just win the game. It's like pause four.
Yeah, I just win the game automatically.
No, I played the old Techies. I didn't even play the new gay
Techies that sucks. I played the old Techies.
Okay, is this just only his scrims or their scrims?
>> Root Mantis, Invis.
It might be secure.
>> But I can play Phoenix, Hela, Hawkeye.
Okay, okay, he needs to Oh, hold on. They've They've negotiated
her into playing Phoenix.
He has to admit he has to say, "Okay, okay." He He needs to say,
"Oh, if you try to I I'll try Phoenix." At least you got to give
something back, man. You got to give something back. They just
gave something, you got to give something back. Let's go.
Okay, that was him, right? Those are all great picks.
Problem? I know you would love a Phoenix. I would love a Phoenix,
I agree. And my damage is absolutely necessary for
I agree for certain composition. Yeah, I think I think you guys
run like a Mantis
for the Invis, and then get a group.
And that should be fine with a Widow.
That should be enough damage, decent heals. Wait, how about there's
no bans, right? Yeah, there's no bans.
You just play Widow the whole >> But if we run into like
Snake Case's team, can you please play Bucky? These cuz these
teams
I don't care. You're making me mad, bro. We've been playing against
Snake Case's team. This is their team. The only difference is
one support player, bro. We won. Shut up now, bro. Like I'm tired
of it. This is getting annoying. You're making Zaza sad. Like
it's not that She's going to play Black Widow, so just shut up
for 2 seconds and just play this goddamn scrim. Y'all don't get
it.
Thank you.
This is I can see exactly how this is going to break down into
the current culture war. Oh, boy. This is going to be culture
war scrims, isn't it? Oz's point. I think
Stop. You're making her sad. Stop making her sad. You're making
her sad. >> the solution would be against their
If you're concerned about their dive, you just trade back lines.
Okay, everyone.
Okay, one.
Skipping through a little bit. I'm guessing they get to hear.
Hold on. Hold on. Looks like Zaza had some good numbers there.
He's not doing as well. Zaza three and four. Here's the thing,
though. Maybe they got a shot if the other teams focus up on
Zaza.
But all the other teams have to do is identify that that Widow
can't hit shots. And if they're smart enough, they identify that
Widow can't hit shots. Right? Especially if somebody starts talking
about how this Widow has like 190 ping, and you just focus on
him, the Magic, instead.
Don't you just win automatically?
We could spot him, I guess. Probably should keep
The current score is
Like a Groot or Venom, Groot Angela.
Honestly, Mag would be fine. Like a Mag
Okay, we're going through a lot of this. Do we need to skip any
of this? Like I'm trying to think of what we can do this if we
can. Unless you guys are enjoying this, I I feel like I enjoy
it. So, as long as I enjoy it, are you guys good? I enjoy going
through all of this cuz I like seeing how the
I can't tell if anyone else is picking stuff up.
Okay, [laughter] all right.
Oh, Chris, can you play a dive support? My bad.
Okay, so Zaza is doing his struggles, [laughter] but
It's a little better. Who's doing it? Just need to run a comp
that can sustain it. That's all. Our our sub is Loki goated,
though. Like can't lie.
Oh, it's Fumia?
It's Fumia or
Beat down comp, so
He's one as well.
Zaza did not have positive KDA.
Looks like Zaza is getting some kills now, though.
Oh, hold on. Was that seven and zero? Oh, she's seven and zero
against this team. Although this team's kind of getting [__]
I link spider. I link spider.
>> Uh some tech that I made.
>> This is like Tracer on steroids. It's It's actually
hard to track her out.
She got pulled back.
Wait wait for me. Wait for me Angie. Nice. Thank you.
By the way, I'll say all I keep hearing from people is well of
course they lost cuz they ran this comp. Did they run the comp
without him?
Cuz like people are like oh well yeah they lost. They played
out the games. They definitely lost cuz they ran this comp. That's
like maybe but wouldn't he have been their best player? Wouldn't
he have been their first draft pick?
if they lost their best player and they didn't have someone to
replace him, of course they're going to lose a bunch of games
in the tournament, right?
>> Okay. So this is
I think
I wish I could see if there's better stuff in here. So essentially
what happened is this is the vibe they're having
and then they complain about this guy to the staff, okay?
Now what I'm getting the sense I'm getting getting the sense
what I'm understanding is it seems like they lied about some
of the stuff he was saying and just how bad it was.
And he posted this to sort of go here's all my vods. Here's like
all the vods of the scrims and was this worth banning me
They're winning this one. I'm guessing this isn't going to be
a raw case too who I believe has been referred to multiple times.
Are we going to see him rage out here? I I think this is the
exact thing if I'm not mistaken this right here this is kind
of the exact thing he was possibly quite annoyed about didn't
want to have happen. Hey against this guy's team please don't
play this cuz it's not going to work out.
Oh they they win, right?
I think they just won.
>> I mean that's not quite so good for him. They just beat
the team he was concerned about, right? It's not against triple
tank though J stock which was his point of having her able to
switch off. Okay, so they were playing the comp that he was concerned
they'd be playing. Got it.
Oh hold on she won MVP. Hold on. This I don't listen to this
one.
When did I talk [__]
Are they thinking silently seething? Silently seething?
Because if people are getting so badly
Wait yeah yeah yeah.
All right. I'm going to go guys. GG's.
Yeah I'm going to go queue ranked. Uh GG
Are we going to fight Ventus' team right
Dude he he got [__] talked one time and he's like
I'm done. I'm out.
Oh no.
Report him for the weak mental, okay? She had one good game and
he's just going to like leave. He gets mocked one time and he's
going to leave?
Dude come on, man.
Come on, dude.
I'm out of Discord player Widow player. Oh that's yeah the channel
name did get
Oh boy.
Seething. Okay sorry he did get [__] talked earlier.
I'm saying right now he is seething.
Sorry sorry. I'm saying that he was wrong. Like as in he was
wrong. This is the time where they could justifiably talk [__]
where they aren't just saying you're being mean. They're actually
saying you're wrong she did good. Admit you were wrong seethe
loser. And now he's actually wrong and he knows he's like he
got kind of owned, right? The second he got kind of owned and
got some [__] talked to him where he wasn't totally
in the right, he's seething and he's like getting ready to leave.
That's embarrassing.
He was just talking them when they were having a bad game and
they didn't leave. They didn't they didn't
>> Okay he stayed for one more. Oh he's speeding it up
actually.
I think I'll I think I'll just I'm just going to go bro. I have
to edit stuff too. I want to go play ranked too. Um see you guys.
Oh no.
Not good.
You're out here coping now.
All right. All right.
Beseem just messaged me telling me I was kicked out. So apparently
the boyfriend of the girl he was and the captain CC both like
message people and said we should kick this guy out of the tournament,
okay? That's the next part that comes up here in the document,
okay? Zaza stack's boyfriend Kaplunk and CC complained, gathered
clips and videos, reported Kingsman to the tournament staff and
BeseemZD
made the decision to kick Kingsman based on what he was told
instead of gathering information. Beseem also admitted that he
would kicked Kingsman hastily without gathering all the information
as well. Here's the archive of the doc that came out. So we will
have the doc here, okay?
This Kingsman response. Wait wait wait wait wait. There's there's
also a a doc from her, right? From CC or
the guy? One man Marvel oh hold on this is new. This is new.
This is new. This is his admission, okay? We'll see what this
guy
The people when they come in here when they hate they're justified
in what they're saying. They're absolutely
They're absolutely right. 100% no question about it. Like there's
no beating around the bush.
I don't know why it's like difficult to admit when you're wrong
and when you [__] up.
Oh this guy's saying he [__] up like he did the guy.
They everybody in the team knew what was going on. Everybody
in this team knew what was going on and right that nobody told
me what this was. That's that's whatever. It doesn't matter.
Just say Oh uh-oh.
What did they say about him?
I don't know what they said. Oh dude
I said he he talks about it on his stream right away.
I I want to say anything but I just like like I want
I just want to
Okay guys I think I'm just going to end my I'm going to end my
stream. I'm going to raid Magew. Okay guys well
uh I was just kicked out of the
I know. I've been messaging Basim for the past like
That's rough, buddy.
nothing could do. I just got to get removed, I guess. Wow.
What a joke, bro.
I mean, like Well, I think I don't think CC's video is out yet.
It seems like I don't think the timing is off here. I think basically
like as their last scrim ends, he gets kicked, right?
That seems to be the actual accurate
>> I can't
>> unreal, bro. Unreal.
That's That's crazy, bro. That's That's
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. That is This has got to be the
craziest thing
to ever happen in my entire life. I am bullied by my own team
like that that uh then like Yeah, bullied by your own >> tournament
for my reaction to that. That's just That's absolutely insane.
Wow. Just Just wow. For real. For real, bro. For real, guys.
Feels like one of those things where we're going to be like,
"Actually, everybody here is going to suck." >> Like just
just watch the Just watch the VOD. I mean, you can see it from
my perspective. That's insane. Bro, I mean, this is this is unreal.
I cannot believe that this is happening right now. All I wanted
to do was join this tournament and play to win and have fun with
my teammates, but they did not want to do that and constantly
[snorts] painted me as a bad guy for
I don't know if that's true, either. Dude, I get that you wanted
to win. what just happened, which is just absolutely ridiculous.
And I mean, like I don't know how it's possible for somebody
to want to win in a $40,000 tournament and, you know, just being
passionate and I think he said eventually. >> Like what
we should play for that to be chick worthy, but I I mean, I don't
know. People people get way more passionate all the time.
I have no disrespect to Basim, but It's getting a call from somebody.
I can only tell from that, you know, you got the You got the
Juju What the [__] is this guy's name from Juju Kaisen?
Whatever this avatar is, anybody who this is about to be a total
misogynist is about to go the [__] off and complain
about women everywhere. 100%. >> Yo, Bernie, what's up,
man? I just finished watching the VOD. I I mean, I didn't insult
anybody. I All I did was just All I did was simply
What are we talking about? He clearly got bullied. The only bad
thing he did was zero HP voice. No, he was He was being a whiny
[__] and then he got bullied a little bit for being
a whiny [__] But I mean, him being a whiny [__]
was bullying, too, by the same standard, right? If you're just
going to complain about somebody annoying you, they were Everybody
there was just complaining about who was annoying them for different
reasons. just suggest the proper team composition and >> I know,
bro. >> tell them what to do and how we're going to win.
>> case is the difference from somebody who really wants
it and for somebody who just doesn't care. That's just unfortunate,
man. It's Cuz like I'm looking at it from your You're a college
student. I trust me, from somebody that's also paying Apparently,
I don't care enough is kind of not caring enough and you're going
to have to just like that's one of the things you're just going
to have to deal with. It's very winnable. Trust me, it's very
winnable. That's what I'm That's what I said, but I don't understand
why I'm being kicked out for that. Like Wait, you're being kicked
out? >> out of the tournament, dude. That's what I just
said. >> you out? For what? Yes! [laughter] Yes!
Like it's insane. What did I do? Apparently, I crossed the line
of professionalism. How? I'm not
I'm telling anybody on my chat to attack them. I'm explicitly
telling my chat to not go in their chat, to not attack them.
My mods are censoring all of the messages that they can see in
the chat that are attacking the person. I know. I Like look at
this. They're censoring me. That wasn't even doing much. Like
they just They're working overtime. I don't understand. Bro,
they're censoring you for for like even trying to insinuate a
rage bait. I have no ill will towards Basim or any of the creators.
I'm only here to just like practice and win with my team, but
then my team just doesn't care. They just don't give a [__]
I mean, like it's $40,000. That's a life-changing amount of money.
I'mma keep it a buck. The problem is is that like I'mma just
be real, man. It's the luck of the draw. You were drafted to
the wrong team. >> Yeah, but I don't understand why I should
be kicked regardless. That doesn't make sense.
It did feel like they could shift to like first like whatever
the draft picks were, you could just shift these people around
to You know, I'm telling you this is what Basim saw. This is
what Basim
Didn't feel like he had to be kicked. >> Basim probably
saw the end of the games. He did not see any of the build-up.
He did not see what they were saying to me in the previous games
and how much they were insisting on running a specific composition
or running blah blah when Cuz he listen, regardless of the fact,
you have every right to
It doesn't make sense. That's the point of a scrim. It's literally
a scrim. You're hard coming. You're supposed to focus to win
the scrim. You're trying to like try different comps, so like
I didn't even realize that Basim That's what we are here for.
I understand wanting to have good vibes and having fun, but I
also want to win. >> Trust me, I get it. Because like I
said, it's a matter of perspective. >> very like passionate
and very intense. And I understand that some people do not like
that. But if I am not like specifically dealing >> behind
it, though. There's a reason behind it. Because truth be told,
you need the money.
I'm reading ahead a little bit. I don't see like a major wrongdoer
here, except maybe like
uh maybe the people who reported a little bit, depending on what
they said, and then the guy who made the decision. I have to
see, is there somewhere where we get it laid out what they told
this guy? They grabbed clips, but like what did they tell this
guy was happening? I will Maybe it'll become more clear when
the CC video Exactly. You [laughter] feel like you're playing
with that You feel like you're playing with that You feel like
you're playing with a team that doesn't care. These types of
businesses, Kingsman, is kind of pushed me. I have a business,
right?
Zaza or Zaza or Zaza stream for now. Going to end stream, guys.
Goodbye, guys. Goodbye, stream. Um
>> Whatever he's talking about it the next >> Now,
to give some more context, here is the draft day of the tournament,
so you guys can understand the perspective that Zaza or Basim
would have had based off of the tournament. >> Captain
W 1 Who's your captain? I don't know. They're drafting.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I got you. Um You know, last time I played
in this tournament, I think I went almost last place, but that
was because I was team captain and I didn't know anyone. I didn't
know who the one tricks were, who were good and who wasn't good.
But this time This time there's a nice little spreadsheet. I
was cooking in there. You know, I'm feeling confident.
Um Yeah, may the best
I don't know. Team captain win. You can have You can have full
rank one
Dear god. So, lots Yeah, half the people in this tourney are
dying games, so. Just that is. Wait, no. It's Or Jarvis figure
out Jarvis got it. Yep, it's CC. Yeah, we're going in a reverse
snake draft. Yes. Wait, did Boker draft? >> CC, who would
you like first duelist pick? Wait, I would like Oh, is that how
it went? I thought this was a first pick overall, but now first
duelist, like DPS. >> Kingsman, please. Oh, okay. Okay.
I'm on CC's team.
That's not bad. Kingsman sounds good. All right, CC. No, I have
no idea what
I'm going off this person alone. And my chat kept saying Kingsman.
They were spamming it. I don't Oh, what? Got to make chat happy.
What?
>> Oh, the rank one hacker guy is nice. Bro, she doesn't
even know who I am. I know everybody. CC [laughter] told me
The draft sheet is getting getting tossed up. We're going to
have to rely on your options.
Is this guy like one of the better player? Like he must be good,
right?
>> absolute good choice as your first duelist. He definitely
did. I just realized
Um the Zaza person said that they fell off because of the people
they were playing with or something. She was getting [__]
over by her comp. Classic
>> CC got last place last tourney, right? And she said
she picked people who she didn't know. And now she's picking
somebody And now she's picking somebody who she doesn't know
again.
What do you mean?
She got Lucy? Yes! It's winnable. Wait. Wait. Actually, wait.
That's actually fire. This is winnable. We We win this. This
is actually doable. Me and Lucy are on the same team. $40,000
tournament. There's no way she's going to throw. So, that means
we're going to actually win. That's actually doable. Okay, CC's
got a a good good draft. Good draft. Oh, he picked Natalie.
I wanted him, bro. I wanted him.
Okay, I What is he talking about for in terms of
Who is he talking about?
Oh my god, it's between All the players I wanted for my comp
are drafted. Samju and Zaza.
Baby Zaza
Oh, no.
>> 250 pings Widow C1 main?
Can I get um can I get Zaza? Samju is a great guy, bro, but he
only plays BP. I want to win the tourney. That's what she can
on Widow, at least. I know you guys are going to Spider-Man No
comment. Any Zaza is good. Wait, where is Oh, true. Okay.
Bro, Benzer's team is so good. He has four one of Everybody on
his team is one above all peop- Bro, Benzer's team is >> Am
I actually the only one above all player on my team? Wait, CC
didn't draft any other one above all players? Lucy Well, it's
just me and Lucy. Lucy, we got this, okay? scrim though. We have
to scrim. We literally have to scrim. Here we go back to the
other And like It's got an RNG Booker got first pick in the
Casey is So,
I don't know what he's trying to edit together here. I just I
don't get what he's even trying to drive us towards thinking.
That's fine. But then so your other duelist is a Black Widow
main and I know you're like I think all the DPS >> Okay,
yes. You know they do black you have but she's really good at
feeling like Spider-Man's and dives.
She does that like she has maximum reps on that character and
then if she doesn't work she tries sometimes swap balance stuff.
I have my trust in in Zaza to >> possible that we can get
her on Phoenix from the beginning of the game instead of forcing
the Widow? Probably not. Okay, well listen listen. If we're going
against five one above all's they are going to full dive Widow
so hard. single There is there is there's a [__]
who was it? I forgot I remember seeing one of the teams that
I recognized literally everybody was one above all. There was
another team that had really good players. I I forgot the name
in a in a C1 against like full one above all's. We can do this.
It's doable. I believe in us but we have to like really try hard.
Like you got to trust my comp suggestions or we're going to lose.
Just like
Let me cook. He was like he was like yo isn't there a chance
that she plays Phoenix first time? Exactly. Doctor we cannot
bro please please please lock it in please. I feel like everyone
that I drafted wants to win. Like I don't no one on my like I
don't know if you're familiar with anyone on on the team but
like everyone is one >> what are your what are your opinions
on forcing triple support off spawn? So you don't want to you
want to want to you don't want to instant force triple >> Obviously
like if we have the win
I feel like you know what I mean? It's like There are no bans.
Is he trying to show that like they were open to the idea? Gambit
Loki are in the game. Mantis is also in the game. So is full
full spawn hold comp is start What's that? I would always I would
always just What? What's the number one rule? Number one rule?
Yeah. Is vibes. We're never winning a game if you tilt my team
bro. No no no. We're Ooh.
Never winning any >> no you don't understand you don't
understand. I'm not going to tell I'm not going to tell you guys.
I'm not going to tell anybody and I never go down verbal. Don't
you don't have to worry about that. Don't worry. Never go down
verbal. >> Number one rule is I'm verbal. I'm Every moment
of the game Every moment is winnable bro. Every moment is winnable.
Trust me trust me. You should have seen me in the PGL okay? You
should have seen me in the PGL. We This is going to be PGL part
two bro. I just want us to win. Yeah, I
I get how he's annoying. I get how this whole dog [__]
I don't think dude do I need
anything else here? Does he have anything that's like
not the exact same [__] What also why was this in
reverse order? I don't I don't get what he's doing here okay?
I love it. If I can get Lucy in here oh we're going to duel you.
How about you My bad. I'm sorry. I'm sorry bro. I'm
You how old are you? I'm 20.
Freaking kids bro. I miss you that.
Okay, I I think we could keep this in the back pocket but I'm
going to start going to some of the other stuff. So, this is
the Kingsman response that I believe he drops is this what he
drops immediately? Why is this all the way up in the thread?
Oh, this is him doing his whole document. Dude, I I'll be honest
I'm not sure I needed his YouTube video but it was fun to watch
for a little bit okay? Now, let's get into this okay? Wait why
does it say copy of Kingsman response? I sent the clips to Basim
that got Kingsman banned from Basim's Creator
Okay, people keep arguing I didn't mention the money involved
so I'll highlight it here. The tournament had a
I'm getting super annoyed at how this information is like not
tracked well. Here this document's [__] worthless.
Fantastic. Uh maybe we've got archives of this hold on.
Would anybody have archived every link in here? Apparently not.
Worthless.
Fantastic.
I'll see if I can find something to find the the clips. I I'm
sure we'll see if we just read through this we'll probably see
a lot of the things we actually watched right?
So, I do think he was kind of complaining but he he suggested
it at first and then he was like oh maybe not 190 MS Widow. He
then brought the money and what it meant to him to win the tournament
where CC made it known that she wasn't too focused on the money
part. This should have upset Kingsman's expectations for his
team's mindset. This was the vibes it's about vibes. Kingsman
then questions Zaza's ping and it was explained to him that she
plays NA and this was unavoidable. CC also warns him that he
better not crash out on her team. This is her the first time
Kingsman was warned about the energy CC expected on her teams.
This is all going to be removed isn't it? Guys going to be gay
everywhere. Yeah, gay gay gay.
Keep in mind he hasn't seen Zaza play yet or interacted with
her at all at this point. Zaza's ping is mentioned again with
Lucyasa
Lucyasa calling her a weak point. Kingsman explains the problem
with ping despite it being out of her control. Potato and not
notalifs are the other OCE
Oh is this one of
OCE creators in the tournament? Is this like the one above that
that can't be it right? No no no no no. What does this even mean?
Oh Oceania like like Australian people. Kingsman then states
he doesn't have an issue with the Widow pick but wants to hide
it from other teams because of the ping difference.
These comments genuinely puts Zaza down and kills morale she
had for the tournament seeing her team doubt her for things out
of her control.
This doesn't make sense I'm sorry this is this is fake this is
false. This is You can not want her to do that but you picked
her on the team like
everybody set this woman up to fail. She joined this thing and
she is like objectively going to be like a weak link. It's just
going to happen and with good players there right? It's obviously
going to happen. It sucks. She was just set up to fail totally.
So, after Kingsman sees chatter told him that Zaza was which
was just untrue Kingsman then attempted to talk with her in VC
to clear it up. Zaza responded in chat as we were still downstairs
in the couch. Kingsman calls his chat a bunch of liars and apologizes.
This was the last day of interactions for draft day. Later on
in his stream Kingsman takes another shot at his team to his
chat stating that his draft for another tourney was way better
than the Basim one. From day one Kingsman goes live and to stream
the scrim he immediately mutes and complains to his chat about
the team comp. This is the first of many instances of this happening.
Okay, so he just whines a lot. Widow into a full brawl dive though.
Okay. I'm getting I'm guessing this will this is all like pretty
explained.
We can try to come back to this document if we can find something
that's got things organized but this kind of sucks
Complaining about the team comp is bannable? No, but like the
vibes of your team is probably something that doesn't go well.
You know what I'm saying? You like totally ruined the vibes for
your whole team. You totally ruined your team's vibes. You are
probably going to get in trouble right? That seems pretty obvious
no? No? No?
You have this one. This is a Google Doc.
The CC files. No, I don't have this one. This could be useful
later. This is her messages or something. I'm guessing this will
come up later. I'm just kind of annoyed cuz I would have like
to see this. It's it's brought up in this Marvel Rivals timeline.
Right? So this is the document of the
But we're not going to have that. We're at this point going into
the CC video okay? So she puts a video out
So Kingsman put his video out complaining. She puts this video
out explaining her side of it okay? So let's give it a listen.
15 minutes consumable very much nice okay? Nicer better.
I thought they lied on him?
That's what Basim said so we'll see.
We're still collecting information. We've not gotten through
everything yet. We're trying to figure it all out.
We're going little by little trying to figure everything out
okay?
I want to start off by saying that I did not get kicked from
the tournament. I was banned on Twitch for violating TOS saying
something toxic to my friend in chat. I've said it before but
this time it was around a bunch of haters so maybe it got spam
reported but it was just for 24 hours. The issue is I can't play
in the tournament while banned because if I get streamed and
I show up on people's streams it counts as ban evasion and I
Wait. Okay, all of your team would be able to stream with you
baby.
Except I don't think that does count as ban evasion. I thought
if you're like not intentionally collabing maybe it would if
you're in the same VC. Yeah, maybe it would never mind. But it
has nothing to do with Basim or the tournament. The problem wasn't
what he said. He didn't get kicked because he wanted his teammate
to swap off Widow. It was because of the way he went about it.
The tone he took and the fact that he continued it for over an
hour after being asked multiple times to stop. It was He was
he was C thing but I don't know if that's like a kick out of
the tournament necessarily.
I think that's like a this is I wonder if the boyfriend kind
of ruined it for everybody cuz what what you do is you have the
team leader the captain the drafter have a serious sit down with
the guy and say like listen
there's a problem. You're making it a problem. Okay? You are
making a problem for us. You need to stop now right? That's what
that's what needed to happen but he didn't get sat down and told
you're being too much of an to continue to play with. is making
the team uncomfortable. We were all playing worse. We were distracted
and team morale was just decreasing and it just was not effective.
Wasn't he winning most of the scrims? And we weren't the only
people uncomfortable. Our own communities were raising concerns
and his chat also told him to chill out. So, this wasn't just
a snowflake
I think this is what Kingsman is most upset with me about is
the green light but I don't think he realizes how little I actually
had in the decision. Basim was going to kick Kingsman from the
tournament no matter what I said. Basim sent me a Discord message
saying hey this is an urgent call are you available? And I said
okay. I muted everything on stream picked up the phone and this
is what Basim said to me. I've been getting a lot of messages
and clips about Kingsman's disrespectful behavior. He was saying
disrespectful things about you guys while muted. He was saying
disrespectful things about the tournament and I'm just not going
to have that so I'm going to kick him from the tournament okay?
And then I say
I need to walk away for a second okay? There's a whole lot of
this wasn't my fault, this wasn't my fault, this wasn't my fault,
right? Going on here.
Now, did she show a screenshot when she was talking about this?
The green light? Yes, this right here, okay.
Uh oh, just the call, okay.
It's not just Bossom's decision. He is okaying it with you. He's
saying, "I want to do this." He's doing it in a way that you
could basically, if you really didn't think it he deserved it,
you could stop it. Otherwise, if if there's no reason to talk
to you, he wouldn't have called you, right? You understand that
you you basically make it so they have to opt in to keeping him
instead of opting out of keeping him. You don't mess if you call
and say, "Hey, do you want to kick this guy out? I heard he's
being disrespectful. Do you want to kick him out?" It's a lot
harder. It's a lot different thing if that's he he opted in the
other direction. He was like, "Okay, I if if if if if you want
to keep him, you can." Which I guess he didn't say, but obviously
that's the tone. And then
I'm I'm kicking him, but you have to let me know you want him.
I get that the extension is not real, but 800 versus 40,000,
that's a little extreme, no? That feels kind of out of this world.
We saw this. We saw this.
And then you guys like kind of talked him. I don't think he said
I think he was actually most for the most part respectful in
the in that game, right?
I think he actually did focus up a little bit, no?
Kingsman cut this part, and as of this video, I'm still banned
on Twitch, but you can check both of our VODs. Okay.
5402, is that on his right here? 5402? Yeah, I do think he was
saying something along like, "Should we really get a a Black
Widow?" Is that kind of
Yeah, other supports are
Okay, it's all a whole bunch of cope rationales. I stared.
Actually, the reason I picked her was cuz she was in the military,
actually.
Yeah, I believe that.
I believe that.
But it's I wasn't
The only time that we talked to Kingsman
Oh, this is funny cuz it's true and it's not true. It's true
and it's not true.
vibes are important.
You also need to be able to go back and forth and like discuss
stuff. And
like I don't think it's reasonable. There's there's like a thing
happening here where he's saying, "Hey, like meta-wise, here's
what we should do. Here's what we should plan for." And they're
like refusing to give at all,
They're refusing to give at all on that idea. So, there's a lot
of there I think on both sides, there's a lot of rigidity that's
not good.
That's not leading to good vibes. It's not just him as much as
he is the author that's very easy to point out that he's an author.
Okay? Cuz he does have a point.
As many authors often do.
This is true. You're not coming back for another season.
That's cope. You have to know No, that's like when you got the
CEO of a company dude, I just had like a whole flashback to corporate
life, okay? When you're like discussing the things you want to
maximize as a corporation, okay? We have these corporate values.
And you have like 12 corporate values. Like, "No, what do we
what's like our number one thing? What's our most important thing,
right?" What's the what's the hierarchy? And they're like, "Well,
no, we have like eight important things that all contraindicate
each other. Quality and speed at the same time." It's like, "No,
shut up. Give me what what is actually important here? Is it
winning or is it having fun? What are you putting above the other?
And it's pretty clear they put having fun above winning. And
people try to do the like, "Oh, you got to put vibes above winning."
It's like, "Okay, maybe
It's not vibes. Vibes aren't number one. You should play meta
Oh, brutal. Um I didn't really think he was that good. I didn't
know much about him, okay? I don't know much about him, but uh
like I just said that so that he would get his ego glazed a little
bit. He'd like he'd get a little bit of an ego
On paper, it says
She used a voice changer to make this video to make her sound
more young. Literally, she has never done this for any other
video. She's manipulative.
You saying she did a voice changer for the 1 HP voice here? The
1 HP The 1 HP voice we're hearing isn't her real 1 HP voice?
Get the [__] out of here.
Get Get the [__] out of here, man. No
I'm sorry. If I'm playing a tournament for $40,000 and someone
tells me they're competitive, I'm going to go ahead and assume
that means they're competitive. I There's no way she doesn't
know what this means. I feel like if you're a creator in one
of these games, you have to know what like competitive means.
That means it's something that you would pick him out as like
above average. He he he likes If they're going to write in a
spreadsheet, it means more competitive than the average like
top of ladder
That means they're a total psychopath,
If I see competitive in a spreadsheet of players who are like
top of the ladder GM players or this one overall thing, whatever
the [__] that is, right? If I see that and it says
competitive, I'm like, oh, that guy's a complete psycho. That
guy is a total psycho. Obviously.
when everyone signed up for the tournament, no one knew it was
going to have a prize pool. No one knew it was going to have
>> All it said was creator cup. Bossom wanted to surprise
us. So, every single person that agreed to play in the tournament
knew that it was a creator focused tournament and that there
was going to be over 50% of the players were going to be one
tricks. That's That's what everyone should have been prepared
Go look at her other videos. She pitched her voice up 100% for
this video.
What hope What do you say, Sage? Are you solo queuing as Widowmaker
right
Oh, that's actually
I thought you were totally psychotic. I thought you were being
totally psychotic.
But hold on, that's actually That's drastic, actually. That's
insane.
Wait, hold on. Wait, different video. >> for the next one.
Come come She was $15? I'm playing What language do you What
is this? Oh, I pretend to be a boy. Hold on. >> wait cuz
you're Oh, there's ghost gone, bro. Wait, how did you just warp
Dude. That's actually
Who cares that it's cheap so that it's normal? Play the game.
>> Yo, where is my payload at? >> Oh, good try, Eun.
Here's your big clutch that you're waiting for that I definitely
know that you definitely weren't waiting for on purpose.
Wow. Looks like they are free
Dude, I I don't know if it's like a voice changer, okay? I don't
know if it's a voice changer,
but there's something going on The pitch is way off.
Hold on. Why does she have so many of these random games that
you I was watching the flank. I was watching the Eun doesn't
have a W A S D. >> watching the flank.
This is the same person? >> called Kingsman a meta slave,
I know he plays magic and I know magic isn't meta. The reason
why I called him a meta slave
Maybe it's possible Maybe she does a voice for
this thing, right?
Yeah, maybe she does like a voice for like this thing where she's
like reading and she's like doing an anime voice cuz it's like
this anime character.
Does she have another video where she's doing the anime character
instead of her?
The truth behind this. Do we find like another anime character
voice somewhere
Indian Tech Hub Hello. But I feel like this game is not going
to go well. I have a sneaky suspicion this Jet's going to be
like a normal human being or it's going to be like a complete
rater or he's going to be racist.
She has like a normal speaking voice and then she she did go
higher there right at the beginning.
says I get
No, boosted ego montage, not that. Hold on. I'm looking There's
got to be somewhere where she did this voice. I'm telling you.
This is how you tell if someone really hates their life.
Guys, we should play Marvel Rivals.
This is how you tell It was because the first conversation we
ever even had was that he wanted the triple support. Then the
second day of scrims, his first conversation with me was that
Dude, this is not her voice. I I do actually think it's a voice
changer now. Like I don't think there's any other explanation
that it's like a gen a genuine pitch shift. Like maybe she grabbed
Voice Meter and and shifted her pitch up a whole bunch or something.
That's crazy.
>> And then, the conversation came to peel. He wanted the
perfect counter to Hulk, Venom, Spider-Man with Bucky. And he
was very adamant about that. He didn't want to even try playing
Black Widow or anything else. He just wanted the Bucky. And that's
why I called him a meta slave because we were arguing for multiple
maps about the same thing about meta. He wants to play meta cuz
he thinks the only way that we can win is So, I called him a
slave to that meta. And you guys like to talk about compromise
like why didn't um Zaza compromise and Kingsman himself said
that he would play Mantis. I know he only said that out of spite
because we
>> He did say that out of spite cuz he knew you guys would
suck with that comp, but you can't even blame him for that. No,
you can't you can't call him on that cuz none of you guys were
willing to entertain his idea. All you had to do was entertain
the idea and then you don't look like a r- But you didn't. You
out of spite, equally out of spite, said, "No, we're not doing
anything else. She's playing Widow no matter what." He was like,
"Oh, well, we'll like we'll roll all this [__] We'll
roll comp to play with Widow, right? That's the Mantis Loki comp
they're talking about, right? Something that maximizes Widow."
And she's like, "No, no, no, no, no, we're not doing that. We're
not doing that. We're not doing that." in an argument and it's
just like, "Oh, here, take it." Like it was a give me. I don't
want him to do something he doesn't want to do. The same reason
why I want Zaza to just play Black Widow. He was not trying to
be a good teammate and make it work. No, he was not. I know that.
She might know that. I'm saying she doesn't get to call him out
on that without like actually walking down that path a little
bit cuz I don't think it mattered whether he was good faith or
not there. She wasn't entertaining it either way. I don't want
to force her to do something she doesn't want to do. Kingsman
called her a hitscan flex, but the reality is she is a Widow
OTP that can play Punisher and Hela Phoenix. Another analogy
is if someone says, "I main Emma Frost, but I can play a Rocket
or Luna Snow." That doesn't make them a strategist main. It's
the same thing. Just because she can play three characters out
of the whole pool doesn't make her a hitscan flex like She has
told Kingsman that she is an
She's not a hitscan flex. Not once has the words hitscan flex
ever come out of her mouth.
She told Kingsman that she's an OTP. Um she never promised Hela
Phoenix
Hela None of that. She never promised She said she could do it.
It wasn't
Oh, come on. >> be like, "Oh, why wouldn't she Like she
spent an hour not swapping. Why is she not kicked from the tournament?"
Cuz that's not against the rules. Eun choosing not to swap from
one character isn't going to break any rules. But if you berate
someone for an hour, that breaks the rules. It's not allowed.
That's why Kingsman was booted out and not Zaza or anyone else.
Yes, I did read out the chat cuz when I'm looking to my right,
I'm reading chat that called him a loser. And then I repeated
it. I shouldn't have read out that chat because it was disrespectful.
It's very hypocritical of me for to dis to say that about Kingsman
and then say that aloud.
Wait, hold on. Hold on.
Wait, what was the chat? I'm I missed what the chat was. >> Eun
choosing not to swap from one character isn't going to break
any rules. But if you berate someone
>> or anyone else.
Yes, I did read out the chat >> Okay, okay. >> have
read about Kingsman and then say that aloud. That's on me. But
I will double down and say replace the term loser with being
disrespectful with or rude. And that's my point. I don't think
Kingsman is a loser. I think he's a good player who just wants
to win. I think I said that because Kingsman was being a loser.
You just criticized and demoralized my teammate for an hour,
repeatedly ignoring our mentions to stop. Like
She didn't say she's a one trick pony. He did say that she could
play Hela or Phoenix. Actual liar, dude. Weaselly little Somebody
said she could play Phoenix. And then people are like, "Oh, could
you switch to Phoenix?" And she's like, "Yeah, I'll try Phoenix."
But did she She actually tried Phoenix? I didn't see that in
the games.
Like that's loser behavior. You're being a loser for that. And
I'm going to say it again. If you make someone sad for an hour
despite people telling you to stop, that's being a loser. And
none of you guys in the chats could even defend
Okay. Well, I think that that Widow made him sad for over an
hour. >> You guys are trying [laughter] to justify that.
There's no justification for being an ass. That's just what that
was. So, it wasn't a personal attack on Kingsman. If If Kingsman
brought
it up to Bossom, be like, Is that not >> That's just facts.
>> That the Widow made him sad? He was being a loser because
he wouldn't let the topic drop. As team captain, I do have a
I guess it's pretty obvious the Widow made him sad, okay. Which
is why I'm taking accountability for the fact that I could have
handled it way better. I didn't have to snap at him. I shouldn't
have told him to shut up. I shouldn't have told him to shut the
F up. I wanted Kingsman to voice his concerns and his wants and
and things with the team, but once it got to a destructive point,
I should have just told him, "All right, you know what? Like
for this game, let's let Zaza just try Widow and if it doesn't
really work, then um we can If you're really adamant about it,
let's just let her Like we can try Bucky or another character."
And I agree, my communication was bad because of that. And then
also In hindsight, maybe a warning would have been better and
not a full kick. But at the end of the day, that's Bossom's decision
cuz it's his tourney. He invited Kingsman to play and he can
easily take him out if he wants to. I also This I just entirely
taking yourself out of the equation. Come on, man. >> has
a list of so many >> Come on, dude. >> right to sub
in. So, saying, "Oh, it's kind of weird how Moxy was able to
sub in within 5 minutes." No, he was just ready. He just has
a list. The same way that I got replaced because I couldn't play
in the tournament on Sunday within the hour. So, don't disrespect
Bossom like that. I That's crazy. And to address the whole bullying
a kid thing, I don't really consider you a kid at 20. I did call
you a kid when I drafted you. Wait, how old is she? She's not
30, is she? is people call me old. And Don't Don't say you don't
consider him a kid at 20 if you're like 10 years older. That's
a kid, dude. Come on. >> cuz to be honest, we were just
offending Zaza. You were on her case for an hour. She already
said no and you wouldn't take no for an answer. And so, we told
you to drop it.
Bro, I know for a fact I could go match up with some I I feel
like I'm so certain. I wish I had a time machine cuz I don't
want to spend time playing Marvel Rivals, but I I feel like I
could get to whatever rank these people are at in a very quick
amount of time. I think it would be nothing. I think I'd do it
so >> was it was self-inflicted that the conversation kept
going because we didn't want this conversation to keep going.
Before I play the clip that Kingsman left out and you hear the
voice of reason from Entei, I want to say that no one no one
on my team hates him. I don't hate him. And I've said this multiple
times, I think Kingsman is a good player. I respect his mentality
and I with him wanting to win, but I was not the reason he got
booted. It was his own actions and behavior that other chatter
and viewers and ultimately Basim did not like. I'm not asking
for an apology. I'm hoping that by the end of this video Kingsman
understands the team perspective more
and sees that like I'm taking accountability. I'm not the perfect
person. I could have navigated it better. You might still be
Kingsman might still be in the tournament if I said something
different or Kingsman might be in the tournament if he did something
different. This isn't black and white. Like it's not about Marvel
Rivals. Not about Zaza not swapping and it's not about you trying
super hard and to win the money. It's about human relationships
and just having more respect for the person you're demanding
something out of and going about it a
This is like fine that you want to say this, but you guys didn't
have human respect either. He went first, but you guys were back.
I I see no reason why he should have been kicked out of the tournament,
right? Like Like she wasn't better than him.
Everybody's fighting against their own demons, okay? He saw these
people who wanted to like not play not not play meta and like
ruin his chance at winning and they saw the incels who every
time they hear a girl's voice on the cat on the mic, they freak
the [__] out and they're like, "Oh, we're we're we're
it's over, right?" >> cuz it's not effective demanding
something out of your teammates that you've just met consistently
even after they've told you no.
Kingsman, what I'm trying to get you to understand though
I am not Listen, you Listen, it's not just Listen, it's not just
Zaza that you're affecting in this. It's also affecting CC and
your entire team synergy because you're complaining about a comp
that they would not authorize. >> [__] talked.
We had a game. You drop it. Then you drop Exactly. Exactly. Exactly.
I didn't say anything. On the last game I didn't even say anything.
But you said You said enough, bro. Dog, listen, I'm trying to
help you. You did say a lot, man. You said a lot. And like I
said, I'mma be there for you because you getting to kicked out
of the tournament is stupid. I get it, but you were overstepping.
You were overstepping the entire time. So, you can't get mad
when all the overstepping that you have done for the past several
days >> Several days. We had one day of scrims after a
draft. That was it. >> Kingsman, what do you realize that
we had Listen, listen, aside aside from what rumors may told
you, I had known from like the cuz I was in everybody's chat.
I'm a viewer. You were crashing out about the team from the moment
stuff
You're crashing out about stuff from the moment you got drafted.
>> That's not a buddy, man. You were overstepping. You
were overstepping more than you realized, bro. Okay, man. I do
think having CC as the leader like it's not to do with her being
a woman. She just didn't lead the team. And listen, I just wanted
a positive tourney experience and it's clear that that's not
allowed with competitive integrity.
Okay. Well, I don't think that's true. All right.
So, we move from there. Let's see. I think I could have sworn
I've seen that CC person on my timeline here. So, I'm a little
concerned. I don't even know where we're going after this. All
right, so CC made a video showcasing her side and was the why
Kingsman got kicked. Black Widow main subs started to feel
the effect as the as the term Zaza is used if anybody who refuses
to swap specifically Black Widow who isn't doing good or hit
Okay, somebody's complaining about this. I don't know who's It's
over, bro. Someone just told me not to Zaza this his game for
picking Widow in quick play and it happened twice today. I hate
my life, dude. I can't even have fun because two of bottomites
took us back to season zero. R/BlackWidowMains
>> Don't Zaza my game, bro. What are you
Zaza, you're about to set us back 30 years. Widow mains watching
Zaza ruin everything for their community.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Starting to get more mainstream, the
Atlanta Hawks NBA team made a meme out of it. What? How Kingsman
felt after watching his old team get destroyed in the Rivals
tournament. Oh, boy. So, they go one and eight is the story,
okay? Overall, they go one and eight. Kaplunk made an apology.
Bro, there's no There's got to be more than this.
Somebody was like, "Wait, could she play Phoenix?" And they're
like, "Yeah." And I was like, "Oh, cool. It's solved." One of
her voices agreed, the other disagreed. Okay. All right. Emotions
were high and I failed to notice which resulted in me snapping
at Kingsman. I apologize as no matter what, raising voices is
instantly shut and instantly shutting down a teammate is not
the right thing to do. I also should have reprimanded the comments
directed at Kingsman once the scrims were over. I needed to hold
everyone accountable. I also apologize for calling Kingsman a
loser and I should not have read that chat in the first place.
It was very disrespectful as Kingsman This is the same as her
This is the exact same as her video.
Even after the initial situation calmed down, CC continued to
bully Kingsman and speak ill of him across social media. CC has
a history of attacking other players and talking trash. Ooh.
So, I apologize for calling him a loser. As a leader, I needed
to lead without emotions and a clear view. I said good vibes
are important, but I failed to create that properly. Before Kingsman's
video went out, I had already reflected, which is why I didn't
realize you guys needed to hear it, too. I'm sorry my Twitter
fingers went first and not this. I tried my best to be ready
as captain preparing a spreadsheet with various comps and play
styles.
But, I learned that everyone being a team captain is or sorry,
I learned that being a team captain is more than strategies.
It's about everyone on the team. They all need to have a say.
What is this? Where is she talking [__]
Oh, hold on. Oh, such a sad attempt at damage control. I do have
like a document of her talking [__] all over the
place,
LOL glazing Kingsman for what y'all Now y'all going to lose.
Wait. LOL glazing Kingsman's for what now?
Y'all going to lose. Kicked out y'all best player. He did it
to himself.
Got your best player kicked from the team. Goodbye 40K. Hello
good vibes. 3K and we got better players and vibes now.
All that energy So, that's what I was thinking putting all that
energy to become a T500 on PC and controller lot blah blah blah
blah blah whatever this is. I'm pretty sure he spent all 20 years
of his life inside playing video games, which is why he lacks
social skills. Ooh.
Ooh, he's a loser.
Yo, Kingsman come Oh, [__]
Oh, oh, [__]
Screenshot this. Y'all think I ain't see the toxicity in the
Kingsman Discord? W not spreading hate from the mods and Kingsman
community.
Ooh, let me just switch back to this timeline really quickly.
CC made an apology. Oh, it was the next thing in the timeline.
Zaza stack has also put out a statement as they were impostor
accounts or there were impostor accounts on Marvel Rivals pretending
to be her. Wait, what did she say?
I'm addressing the screenshot right now because this needs to
be made clear. Before the drama, there were impostor accounts
going around and hiding behind my name to act like this. I would
never say this sort of stuff. That is not me.
The only thing The only games I've played since the drama have
been all been live on my last stream and I have not loaded up
the game since. I have also attached a screenshot of my last
ranked game so you guys can see that I've not played anything
any anything
The times in the screenshot and my history are in Australian
Eastern Daylight Time or something. Who knows?
Justice for Kingsman. Justice for that guy? He is black. I don't
give a [__]
>> Just going to make her look racist now.
Absolutely destroyed.
I've also made my Rivals account history public for anyone who
wanted to fact check this themsel- themselves. People don't understand
that multiple players can have the same name with Russian letters.
Exactly this. Thank you.
You called me the Winston of Marvel Rivals referring to my skin
color 2 weeks ago. Was that a fake account, too? It would have
been a fake account because that was not me and I'm sorry someone
called you that. That guy's got no followers. That guy just made
that up. That guy just made that [__] up.
Blood just made it up. 1.5K likes.
And we're And we're supposed to believe you, why? You've been
lying since the drama started. She's lied several I haven't lied
once, bro. She has lied several times. Wait, what did she lie
about? Let's do a quick fact check on that. Lied about not knowing
about the Google Doc your boyfriend wrote, but there are VODs
that show otherwise. Lied about screenshots taken from you trash
talking. You are locking replies to not be destroyed with facts.
Take your own advice and shut up.
Where are those VOD links? Bro, I knew there was going to be
like way more cool [__] as a part of this drama that
we're not getting cuz people are so invested and I'll be honest
like at this point [__] kind of sucks.
[__] kind of sucks. Apparently, there's But, this
document right here this kind of sucks. Zaza stack also put out
a statement apology to Kingsman.
Sorry it's taking me Oh, hold on. Dude, they all they all lost.
This was today. This was this morning.
Hold on. Sorry it's taking me a while to write up Oh, I see a
thread there. Hold on. What is this? Thread 102. No, no, no.
Zaza stack states she never knew her help write the Google Doc.
However, had retweeted several tweets containing the doc as an
attempt to defend herself.
no. No, no, no. >> CC, did you see the document Cap was
putting together about it all? Rage bait for more views? I'm
not a rage baiter,
I'm not
Zaza was all for the doc according to this clip.
He tweeted it? Yeah. Yeah, he's
He's being very like straightforward about everything and putting
all the evidence in there, too. He's actually Cap has a lot of
experience writing good documents like that, so
W Cap.
Kingsman leaked DMs on Twitter, I believe. Oh.
Damn. Okay. Dude, I She is saying she didn't know about it. That
seems to say otherwise, though.
That is That is a lie.
Amumu would still queue up with her with this hoe after knowing
she's like this. Crazy. Why you take a shot at a moo moo out
of nowhere? The [__]
Okay, hold on. Zaza saying support Kingsman like it's Israel.
What?
Oh, this is the loser bit.
>> That's just what happens. That's such a That's such
a good point. You're so right about that. And we're still going
to play Widow. I I need this for my college.
I need this for my college. I have about six or seven
more years.
Oh, man. Some of the stuff didn't get highlighted so well in
his doc video that had no highlighting on any of the important
moments.
Hold on, I need
I don't Dude, I I made food earlier today and I swear to god
I like grab my Oh, I'm an idiot. God damn it. Okay, we're good
to go. All right, that's important. That's an important bit right
there, okay?
Even after the initial situation calmed down, CC continued to
bully Kingsman and speak ill of him, and that's this.
We looked at this, didn't we? WeeGee the third. This WeeGee the
third guy has been on it, yeah. We looked at this one. Okay,
but I didn't see the support like it's Israel.
A genuine question. >> is right here. What? Like seriously,
answer this even if you support Kingsman, whatever. Support Kingsman
like it's Israel.
whatever whatever you have in your head. I have a genuine question.
I have a genuine question.
What does that mean?
What does that mean? I'm saying
whatever whatever you have in your head. I have a genuine question.
I have a genuine question. Ready?
I'm saying
I have a genuine question.
Does she just mean Zela? I don't know what she means.
The [__] does she mean? I literally I don't know
what she means, dude. Okay, hold on.
Tweet pointing out the boyfriend's lies from the doc, I assume?
There are a lot of clips
and there are a lot of clips. Don't back pedal. Taking accountability
is a lie among everything else. It was clear Kingsman was bullied
during the VODs. Just watch them. Not once did Zaza say Did Did
he say Zaza was bad? He said Widow wouldn't work, then told to
shut the [__] up. Horribly handled all around. >> CC,
did you see the document Cap was putting together about it all?
CC, did you see the document What's the other
Huh? Oh! The inline updating? Uh-oh.
Wait, which line of the document was it? What the [__]
Dude, what the [__] am I
I was like, yo, the script keeps moving. What is happening? >> Oh
my god.
I assume that's updating while people were viewing it, but
let me grab his document really quickly and we'll see what updates
there
Here's a doc. Initially, the tournament had also had no bans.
This was to facilitate creators known for certain heroes to be
able to play their heroes in the setting. Okay.
God damn.
The damn Okay, hold on. I think there are some updates from today,
so I'm I'm just looking to see if we got more
Wait, this was This might be a higher resolution version of the
clip. Give me a second.
That looks like a different avatar with more pixels, dude. What
the Oh, hold on. How much time we got? 38 minutes. Guys, if you
like the content, go ahead, throw a couple subs in. Go throw
a couple subs in the pot and the pot, okay?
Please mute. Yeah, I Is that even Bro, am I crazy?
People are so on this guy's side. I don't think People are so
on this guy's side. This doesn't even What does this change?
Why is this even bad?
The reaction is like totally disproportionate to anything that's
actually happening here. This is so bizarre, man.
This is so [__] bizarre. Basically, they're like
all talking about how this guy was like bullying the one girl
and then this is her >> this guy is a diaper exploder like
a bug. That's just what happens. That's such a That's such a
good point. You're so right about that. And we're still going
to play Widow. I I I need this for my college.
I need this for my college. I have about six or seven
more years.
They're making They're making fun of that guy for wanting the
money from the tournament. This Kingsman guy. They're mocking
him. They're mocking him being poor. How [__] up
is that?
So sad.
It's crazy, man.
Okay, hold on. I just need to make sure I've got all of the stuff
out from this cuz I think we've seen basically everything except
that he was streaming to like way more people now.
I got Twitch partner. He kind of He kind of just won entirely.
He was a small streamer. He had nothing. Let's look at the difference
actually now that I'm thinking about it.
I do just want to see if we've got I think I caught up on everything
for
Oh, wait. Hold on. There's all the CC doc, right? The CC files?
We do need to do the CC files real quick. Oh, and CC had a sponsor
pull out as well. So, the girl who's the captain of the team
had a sponsor pull out.
I have to finish this segment and then we can get on to like
Ice or something. We'll do something fresh here. Just give me
a second.
So, InfinityMice, this is one of our sponsors. We've been made
aware of a situation involving CC during the recent creator tournament.
While we worked together previously, we do not support behavior
that targets or disrespects other creators. As a result, we will
not be continuing any partnership moving forward. We believe
in keeping competition respectful and we wish everyone the best
going forward. Bro,
I don't think this was that crazy that she deserved to lose a
sponsor, but I have not seen the CC files yet, so I do want to
see real quick.
Originally, I wasn't planning to post anything else on this,
but I saw this. Uh I don't think so. They've been at it for at
least an hour. It's between matches and rounds and it flares
up again. Going alts going alts. Clip anonymously. Download clip.
There's anything that can help hit us get him kicked off the
team. Don't worry, plenty of people in line just as good. Kingsman
like everybody else is replaceable. Playing for the money was
Playing for the money. Get the [__] out. There was
no bans. Yeah, I'll go through it. That's not CC, is it? That's
not CC who's censored here?
There's no way that CC herself
Have we got any announcement of who this was? Cuz Hold on.
If there's anything else that can help us get him kicked off
team. Who's us? Who's us?
Well, this is Kaplunk. This is the boyfriend of the girl who's
getting
for playing Widow? All right.
That's too long for CC. No, it's not. She had the cat tag.
That's actually about the perfect length for CC and then the
cat tag.
It's not too long at all.
Uh is your title about Basim?
What is this? Why is this
And this is just blind speculation, but This is likely the first
and probably Marvel's only Marvel's rival Dude, what is this
picture? We get this pulled out? Yeah, thank you. Wait, what
is It's literally this.
Wait, is this clip This clip from her stream, isn't it? Or something?
It looks like there's somebody's taking this out of his stream.
Hard to tell.
We'll keep looking. This is just blind speculation, but the fact
that she was referring to it as helping us get him kicked off
means that multiple people were trying to do that on my team.
Kaplunk is Zaza's boyfriend. This is her
Kaplunk is Zaza's boyfriend and I'm assuming this message is
one of one of the is with one of the team members. I'm 99% sure
it's CC. Either way, my vibes were off. So, there's So, here's
the DM DMs between me and her the day after I got kicked and
posted the video right after the tournament started. Please,
bro, do something. These NPCs in my Discord server, TikTok chat,
Instagram comments, streams. I told them not to harass anyone
like 40 times in my vid. If you have like Twitch names, I can
ban
So, I've ignored messages. I'm not deleting the video. It's legit
just the VOD, but I have already told my viewers like a trillion
times not to harass anyone and I'll keep saving that saying that
at the start of my streams.
Oh, boy. Holy [__] they think I'm responsible for
banning you when all I said was, "Okay, I agree, Basim." He was
going to boot you anyways no matter what I did. I wish you asked
for clarification before you posted this godforsaken video. Instead,
I'm here fighting panic attacks and mass banning people on X
different platforms. Make sure Make another post or delete the
video if you really care. Hello, do you have any response? Just
like you want 40K, I want some peace of mind for the next time
I go live. Oh, no. He's got all the power now. He's got all the
power.
I'm not So, he's already saw this message. I don't know why this
is like out of order, it seems like. Oh, cuz they're both ignoring
each other, maybe?
I'm not deleting the video. Why not? You took my clip out of
context before even asking me for clarification. You can re-upload
the VOD again. No. The VOD is staying up, dude. I'm not taking
it down. Nothing is out of context. It's just the 16th and then
the draft from a viewer's perspective.
The VOD is staying up. Blah blah blah blah blah. You insinuated
I was the one who got you banned. You put a screenshot a random
Discord message from someone else saying I was sus for going
into a one-on-one call with Basim.
You said in the same vid, "I have a boss call with Basim." and
in the same vid you say, "I green-lit it." I'm not here to argue,
so
Oh, sorry. Are you uncomfortable that I'm not taking no for an
answer the same way you didn't take no for an answer for an hour?
Or the fact that the only thing you said to the team was about
money? Like seriously, bro, why the [__] I want Why
the [__] would I want to kick you if I insisted you
stay after you said you're going to go play ranked? Thanks for
throwing me under the bus and into unlimited harassment for X
amount of weeks, if not months. Get your clicks now all because
of your own actions got you banned and you can't accept that.
Usually, I'd be mature, but I don't owe you that if you can't
even see how you're in the wrong. You're an ass for harassing
Zaza for a whole hour and making her upset even after we said
to stop said to stop. Now I'm getting the harassment tenfold.
Sorry to hear that.
>> He really He really just hit her with I'm sorry to hear
that.
Dude, she did that whole thing nine nine
I'm sorry to hear that. I'm sorry to hear that.
Sorry. Stop lying. You're not sorry.
I mean you also just got banned from Twitch the same day for
your actions which is a totally separate matter. Some messages.
Here this is where this one is. Uh, for what actions LMAO? I
said something in chat to my friend. Okay. I'm done talking.
Good luck in the
Dude, he's kind of winning these DMs after the fact. I I wasn't
on his side at all. He's just like an incel. But now now he's
kind of winning. Now I'm like kind of on his side actually. Okay.
Okay. It's completely unrelated. Unrelated. I'm done talking.
Good luck in the tournament.
You know, I hard defended you when Entei drama farmed. I got
into major drama in creator discord with a bunch of people just
dogging on me for being upset Entei went behind my back to talk
about you to talk bad about you and luck. I creators tell me
how you're a crash out and that's
and that it's not good. I got you on my team and I still defended
you. I ain't ever met such a narcissist like you.
She then removed me from her discord server from the discord
server with real rivals creators all over TikTok where we
And apparently she was the owner LMAO.
Also on a side note, why am I getting messages like this? I've
been keeping up with the drama between you and those females.
This is going to be the most misogynistic message we've ever
seen. And even if I'm late, my blood is boiling so I'm going
to write this essay about it. At first, I felt for you since
I've seen something similar happen to someone I know on a smaller
scale. And then I saw the last two minutes on your video like
23 minute on Basim's VOD where you where you shared your combos.
After watching those last moments, I think you really deserve
to get crushed. Oh, hold on. You let them gaslight you and gave
Zaza a pass to use the misogyny card against you. Oh, he wasn't
he wasn't hard he didn't go hard enough for this guy. This guy's
too misogynist.
Like this guy's like you didn't go hard enough, bro. You actually
you bowed to the women and we can't accept that, okay? We can't
accept it.
You you gave Zaza a pass to use the misogyny card against you
and you made it work. People like you who fold like little female
worshipping F-slurs are why gaming in general in competitive
content creation is going to
She was literally calling your viewers and when there's even
the slightest pushback or you treat her as an equal peer, everyone
freaks out including the cuz they're including that bulk that's
Basim cuz they're women. In the end, you proved to be a little
[__] who cares more about being not being perceived
as a misogynist even though you never even showed any signs of
it than standing up for yourself. You're a disgrace to any self-respecting
human and I hope life you by the very women you claim not to
hate. Oh my goodness. Unless of course you change your ways.
Dude, I I'm sorry it was so obvious between you and those females.
I'm like this is going to be the craziest we've ever read in
our entire lives. It was like obvious from the first first sentence,
bro.
Dude, that is crazy. Holy [__] All
Dude, dude that was nuts. That was
pretty awesome. [__]